26 years old went to vegas we had a nice
[ __ ] week had a great week
right after your show they had like some
sort of cover band or something right
playing all those songs and now every
time i listen to music i'm like and
steve simone and i were talking about it
i wish i could play any kind of
instrument i just why don't you [ __ ]
go i did i took a guitar lesson my
fingers were short today
my fingers are too short for guitar i
understand i'm i don't think my brain is
fast enough
you'll play the skin flute every night
all right good
you could play the [ __ ] drums i seen
you move your little [ __ ] hands look
at you
yeah be cool i don't know you should
learn something you're a young guy it'd
be great it'll be live from your uncle
joey i didn't do [ __ ] with my life you
know what i'm saying he did something
with your life i always want to play an
instrument too i never had the balls i
went down and i played the bass in the
fourth grade or some [ __ ] for a year
basically funny i tried violin and i
tried guitar jews liked the violence
they liked violence oh yeah she would
have loved it i probably could have gone
with it but i was doing it in first
grade and i hated it my friend uh
jessica want to tell me with the book
she plays the violins really yeah she's
you know jessica oh yeah i know yeah of
course she plays the violin that's a
badass [ __ ] what's happening lisa yeah
what the [ __ ] kind of great 26 that's
all you got for me the [ __ ] violin
[ __ ] how about i hit in the head
with that [ __ ] thing ten times gives
a [ __ ] about a violin it's monday
[ __ ] sharpen your dicks somebody's
got your [ __ ] lunchbox somebody's got
your lunch money in their [ __ ] pocket
and you're walking around hi did you see
louie last week get the [ __ ] out of here
it's [ __ ] your week we had a good
time vegas very very nice uh
you forget how much fun you have in
vegas and you don't need
much you know like you don't i just
realized how much i didn't like the
strip
really oh i it's like times square and i
hate times square yeah i [ __ ] hate
listen i want to thank the south point
casino i want to thank ralphie may for
turning me on to them introducing me to
mike the general manager uh
i went there about a year ago and did
the dirty at 12 30 and it was great and
he told me he'd bring me back for a
weekend
and he brought me back for one night and
it was a sold out show thank you for
everybody who came out from the vegas
area i love you [ __ ] you know
uh
it was great we we flew in lee drove in
you know i met steve
i did mma junkie i got to hang out with
george i got to hang out with my friend
mario arias from the sixth grade
i did some tv show channel 13 we ate
nice you know i had some nice [ __ ]
eggs yeah a nice piece of salmon and
then after the [ __ ] show the the
gentleman's like take it whatever you
guys want sushi
and lee and the other guy like now let's
go to steak and shake yeah it wasn't
[ __ ] bad the shake was delicious well
i was well let's just be fair
i was probably top 10 high of me being
high really
oh yeah yeah i was like well i could
still talk but i was actually dolores
don't [ __ ] around no i just had the
frosting
500 milligram brownie auntie delores
don't
[ __ ] around because we drank that
milkshake i went upstairs
i didn't even drink water before i went
to bed i usually drink some i [ __ ]
passed out oh so you think you were
[ __ ] high i was three sheets to the
winner oh i know you i know you were i
was stoned tonight
but they came up to me they're like
where do you want to go to eat i'm like
i have no idea
and i thought you were going to go to
bed and then we finally decided on that
and that milkshake was amazing it was
amazing it was it was a really good time
i had a nice saturday
i left vegas at 7 20 in the morning who
leaves vegas at 7 20 and i had to be on
saturday
six
and uh there's my man right there
i'm just trying to wake you up
[ __ ] we'll be waiting for you a
little while love you
and uh
something happened really weird on
saturday i talked to you guys about it
it really [ __ ] up me all day
first off i want to give my condolences
to the hashmore family one of my buddies
glenn gary hash where he died
yeah he died he was like 58 and he had
he was sick you know uh
i have a lot of i've seen a lot of
american short tragedies you know and
one of the biggest tragedies in my
lifetime was where i've seen at hash
ways you know that that family i've been
eating at hash rate since
they're one of the best
top five delis i've ever been in my life
the roast beef
with swiss on rye with mayonnaise salt
pepper yeah oh my [ __ ] god a little
piece of tomato oh my [ __ ] god
you know she used to make the uh
she used to make the [ __ ] uh
the rolls with the turkey fresh oh the
turkey okay every day the turkey the
roast beef
everything fresh he said it was
basically your like lunch room like you
didn't eat in the cafeteria no no we ate
there and uh
i saw them grow
uh in 84 which is 30 years
ago in september the business died there
was a bunch of rumors the business
didn't die the business burnt down uh we
were across the street we were at the
bar across the street and also the
firing just showed up
and they're all [ __ ] you know putting
water on ashways and we're sitting and
it was glenn gary the mother and the
father they got there at six in the
morning let me tell you something if you
went in there in the morning they didn't
even make egg sandwiches they make cream
cheese on jelly on a kai's roll have you
ever had that no that puts 29 000 pounds
on you cream cheese and jelly on a
kaiser roll with a [ __ ] you
you know we were talking that day with
lee that one i used to i used to go to
north bergen as a youngster
uh in the sixth grade for breakfast in
the fifth grade i would walk from 22nd
street in new york avenue in union city
to like 16th street 17 street numbers it
was old old old italian bakery there
this is before [ __ ] sixth grade and i
would walk in early in the morning like
at six i'd walk in there and i'd get a
loaf of [ __ ] italian bread the hard
[ __ ] with the flowers still on it mm-hmm
and i get uh
i get a bag of zeppeli's
and on the way home i get a uh a stick a
hotel bob a brand butter yeah and i get
a 64-ounce coke and i go home and eat
the whole piece of bread with the whole
stick of butter and the whole bag of
[ __ ] zepplies
that's how much of a [ __ ] savage i
was but then after i got old i would go
to hashways and
uh
ashways gary was the guy who saved me
the day my godfather was chasing me with
a motorcycle was gonna [ __ ] kill me
and i ran through the thorn bushes there
was a big rose pedal and i ran through
them and had a thousand [ __ ] thorns
on me i was bleeding from everywhere oh
no and i went into hash ways and uh mr
and gary hashway who went out there with
me and yelled at my godfather get the
[ __ ] out of there and then
so i felt really bad so my condolences
go to the family i know they're having
like a
a small memorial on wednesday i won't be
able to make it i'll be here but
but something else happened i woke up so
we did the show right
and uh
we
went out whatever when we went to the
room i fell asleep the next morning i
got a wake-up call at 5 30. you know i
got up at five whatever
the car is picking me up at 5 30. i got
up at five got ready drinking coffee i
was already packed i got the [ __ ] out of
there but i went downstairs the car was
picking me up at 5 30 and i knew it was
only a 15 minute ride to the airport
so i went downstairs about 5 25 and i
gave
the guy the bag and i go let me just get
a seattle's coffee just to get the
next kind of coffee
and i was looking over at these tables
and
i don't know how many blackjack tables
you can do with that man 10 15 15. there
was three tables
of young kids i mean if i had a guest
anywhere from
21 to about 26 27 the oldest you know
there was nine or ten of them they all
knew each other they were playing on
three different tables really oh wow
i'm looking at these guys and
they're laughing they're giggling i
looked at all them individually they
were not high on any drug you know just
by look on their faces and if they were
really creepy they had alcohol on their
hand
but i could tell they weren't really
intoxicated too much right they just
give a free drink they were a group of
friends that went out and got drunk and
got high or whatever they they play
cards you know it's six o'clock and
they're giggling and then do you
remember when i called you yeah and when
you said to me you're coming home like
oh no go take a hundred out and go
gamble you're twenty years go laugh and
giggle all night and i i love i've done
that a bunch of times where
you could hopefully i i lost a couple
hundred just really quickly but they
have some good rules there and if you go
on like if you start like 10 or 11
o'clock at night it's very easy
to not even be down money and just be
playing all night if you're playing like
15 20 hands i love that [ __ ] i love and
then it's almost like being at a bar
where you make friends because
everyone's high-fiving you got a
blackjack it's a lot of fun you know i'm
looking at these by and you're right it
is a lot of fun that giggling
in the middle of all that man i said to
myself
i've never done that
really
never done that like i've never
hung out with friends in vegas and
cheered for my friends to gamble and
just just turn out and giggled like that
i'm looking at these guys and i and
i was getting very envious i was getting
very jealous not like not very jealous
but i got a little jealous it was more
on the envious side
but the most important thing i got was
hurt like i was very hurt that's the
first time like i've been hurt by life
and i've always known it i just didn't
let it hurt me because i've done a lot
of things but there's a lot of things i
haven't done and the reason why i never
did them was because i was too busy
doing drugs
the reason why i was never in a casino
at 5 30 a.m with a bunch of guys and
three or four girls giggling and
clapping and just
drinking a gin and tonic and nursing it
and just being yourself was because
i could never do that i i always thought
that was like [ __ ] craziness
like why would you want to be in vegas
if you wouldn't want to be in some room
with two other people doing blow hiding
from [ __ ] each other you know
and that's what it all dawned on me i
was like look at those guys you know
giggling having a good time they're
probably gonna go upstairs their dick's
gonna work they're gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of those young girls and they're
gonna go to bed and have a good time
they're gonna wake up in the morning you
know they're gonna go eat breakfast and
giggle they're probably talking about
louis ck episode
they're probably talking about the new
plan of the apes you know yeah you know
whatever they're talking about doesn't
matter i never got to do those things
because i was always too busy upstairs
doing drugs and it's [ __ ] sad 51 how
many times i've been to [ __ ] vegas
lee 30 [ __ ] time yeah and i've never
done that i've never gotten a cigar and
sat down stairs and just you know and i
have i can't lie to you guys like
there's times i go back and rogan those
guys go out and i just walk around
mandalay bay and play the black jacks
you know it's about one but i mean what
those guys were doing it was genuinely
fun from the heart
there was no weed involved maybe they
smoked a joint but i could tell by their
faces nobody was creepy
you know when i when i was younger i
always thought i needed blow to bring me
happiness like from the age of 21 that
was the worst thing about growing up in
that in that
in that whole [ __ ] era you know
uh even like gary hashman those guys
when i met gary ashford we were just
decent people we were just going along
the 80s and all of a sudden he was
[ __ ] up on blow his brother was [ __ ]
up on blow i was [ __ ] up on blow
but the whole thing was like in in when
i was growing up you needed blow to have
a good time
and the addiction took over
and and it was always blow induced like
i couldn't do anything unless cocaine
what are we gonna do in vegas we're
gonna go to vega i would have to hook up
to coke because i would hang out with
you for a little wobbly yeah and i would
have to disappear like 11 30 when you
weren't watching and go and play my
[ __ ] freak game yeah it's really sad
that
i'm 50 sometimes missed all those years
i missed a lot of just genuine fun from
your heart
all those years that's something that
you know i have regrets i didn't join
the service
i have regrets i didn't play college
basketball i couldn't you know i didn't
have it together
but that regret burned me all [ __ ]
day that really yeah that i wasted
i wasted you know
a [ __ ] third 27 years
just doing blow just because i and i
didn't think it was cool and i think i
was cool
just because whatever pain i was putting
out it's funny that the cards like
triggered that like i would never
imagine seeing people playing cards
would trigger that with you well it
wasn't the trigger it wasn't the cards
it was the laughter uh it was the fun
with your friends
it was the whole camaraderie thing that
you know i sold i sold that part of my
life to be in a room
high paranoid you know [ __ ] boozed up
you know talking to some chick i could
care less about getting into her pants
and that poor girl god knows what's
going to happen you know
i never really had genuine fun like that
these kids are having genuine fun from
their hearts they were giggling they
were saying stupid [ __ ] to each other
i've never done that man you know
and it's funny but if you ask them
they'd probably want to be up in the
room with a girl i mean i'm sure they
were having fun at that point but i've
gone to vegas with friends like the
night i stayed up one night for over 24
hours playing and
i was with the friends who just wanted
to walk around vegas where i sleep by 11
o'clock
like i i would be interested to know if
all three tables knew each other because
i've been on a lot of tables at like 5
a.m where like you're laughing and
you're high-fiving it's completely total
strangers
yeah so it's just uh
it was just amazing that i didn't have a
life until i got off that [ __ ] powder
you know and
yesterday i answered i think 66 emails
it was a quiet week yeah and i had a
couple like addiction emails and it just
it just uh
well you must have done something right
because it's not like you don't have any
friends from that period you still have
a lot of friends yeah that's not you
know having the friends is not the point
we it's the point that
that front that laughter wasn't genuine
that good time wasn't genuine
i always needed something you know when
i was when i was 18 19 and we would go
you called me what are we doing i don't
know
you want to go into the city yeah did
you talk to anybody yeah i talked to joe
gash we're going to pick up koilu's at 5
8.
all right i should make a call let's
pick up a pack you know it was never
just us two just going out yeah my
relationships early on we're all drug
relationships so nothing was done
unless something was there for us
something was dead a snort something was
there to take
and it's just sad it's [ __ ] sad and
uh
you know i look at my life now i look at
all the things i did after i got clean
i did so many things i got a career
really on top i got married i had a
child
i i cleaned up all my debt i got rid of
so many little things that
i wanted to do for such a long time but
i couldn't do them until i could get off
the drugs
and i get all these email addictions and
all this problems addiction i'm gonna
tell you something man
if you're doing drugs today you're
listening to this podcast you're
probably going joey that's because
you're a [ __ ] lop i do coke and play
blackjack all the time and have a good
[ __ ] time you know what today
today you're doing that
but you know what you're going to keep
doing blow and somewhere on the line
it's going to get dark on you like it
did for me like it did for everybody
else who does it
my point today's podcast if you're doing
something right now man
get [ __ ] clean you know i'm an old
[ __ ] i tell you this a thousand times
i have regrets in my life
not joining they you know the service
and all this [ __ ] but lately i've been
really regretting the drugs man
and i would never
thought i'd say that to anybody like i'm
really and i had a great time with him
yeah mugged hookers you know i [ __ ]
shot kidnapped people i had a great
[ __ ] time
but i really missed the essence
i miss the essence of what a good time
is what it is to
just go out on your own wits and giggle
have you had a good time like that since
you've been off the drugs do you think
yeah yeah a lot of good times yeah
genuinely like you went home and said
wow
you know that was a good time couple
weeks i took the baby to the park and
i'm gonna get in the car going i could
not
i wouldn't have met those people and
wouldn't have been in a good mood to
talk to those people if i was still on
powder
if i was still addicted to coke i'd be
at this park with her yeah but the
underlying theme
would be to get her home so i go pick up
a coke rock
wow you know how many times a day do you
think about coke like now yeah today
none none well maybe not not about doing
it but i'm like how you how how your
life
sometimes when i'm driving and i'm gonna
light
a song come on like let's say golden
earring the other day came out i thought
about a situation where a buddy of mine
got stuck one day in traffic coming back
from the city and that was a song that
was on and his cassette that got stuck
and you know
what the [ __ ] who has three you know
yeah usually you're thinking oh i was
getting a [ __ ] behind the church to
that in the eighth grade no
me and a buddy of mine the car the
cassette broke and that was the cassette
that was in the [ __ ] thing you know
and i'll shake my head and go everything
with me is a [ __ ] drug story
you know it's like a one-trick [ __ ]
pony everything with me but it was such
a big part of my life you know when i
tell people i was a junkie i look at you
and expect to see a junkie a broken down
guy i was a junkie because emotionally i
was done
i needed drugs to fuel my emotions every
[ __ ] day because i was in such pain
and i didn't know this until recently i
didn't know i was walking around in pain
until recently because i can notice the
difference
that something you know uh last week i
was walking around in physical pain my
knee hurt yeah my wrist hurt somebody
threw me on my shoulder it hurt [ __ ]
my shoulder hurt from yesterday somebody
threw me on my shoulder you know i'm
trying to do a back row
i can't do a [ __ ] backwards just roll
backwards yeah i can't do it backwards i
can throw my feet up and i follow my
toes with my look and i could do it
halfway and yesterday one of my buddies
from john jacques
just kept doing it with me just for me
to get the feeling a man it does hurt
it's a lot of that's a lot of weight on
my shoulder but
the purpose of this [ __ ] story was
just to tell you man that in the back of
your mind
just like in the back of my addicted
mind at the time i thought i was having
a good time you're really not having a
good time man and you may be having a
good time now but do me a favor just get
off it now while it's still a good
[ __ ] time you know i wish i i don't
and let me let me get something straight
if i would have done coke from 1988 it
would have been great
if i would come out to prison come out
and never did coke again it wouldn't
have been so bad
that was what really [ __ ] me up is
that i came out of prison and continued
to do it for another
you know
12
18 [ __ ] years so you don't wish you
didn't stop before prison like i felt
like like i should have stopped i
usually i'm pretty good with all that
[ __ ] i get a [ __ ] warning and i stop
life throws me something and i look at
the if there's a message and i'm [ __ ]
done i'm very good like that
this i never got a message of the pain
was so much that i never got a message
of and once the pain set off and i got
divorced and i went through that [ __ ]
with my daughter and it just kicked open
again it was like kicking up in a
[ __ ] scab what the scab wasn't even
healed right and i picked at that scab
again and that's what [ __ ] happened
so do you think if you're if if you're
truly addicted to like a drug
if you don't hit rock bottom is it
possible to get off of it like yes do
you think so yes because someday you
have to
it's a there comes a day that you're
gonna say i'm sick of this [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] sick of this [ __ ] isn't that
rock bottom though
well
rock bottom could be a lot of things
rock bottom could be you spend all your
money your wife leaves you yeah you know
rock bottom could also be you could be a
[ __ ] gazillionaire
and your wife doesn't know about your
problem but you're living in hell okay i
was rock bottom i wasn't a gazillionaire
i didn't have any [ __ ] money but my
wife knew but didn't know about my
situation she wasn't my wife at the time
she was my girlfriend
she knew and she didn't know about my
situation you know
uh
i didn't hit rock bottom but i hit rock
bottom
physically and emotionally physically i
could feel the pain in my spine from the
blow
it was i was starting to get jolts from
my central nervous system and my spine
up by my neck
and i knew something was gonna happen i
knew that i was gonna die
or get electrocuted on my own or
something but you know what man like i
said i didn't have i wish i would have
got off the blow august 15th of 1988
soon as i got sentenced to prison
if i would have been smart enough it
would have sank in and i let a lot of
other bad habits go but i never let the
main bad habit that was [ __ ] me up
the most
but i never let that go yeah and and i
and i felt the pain on saturday that's
what i'm trying to [ __ ] suck i really
felt the pain you know me i don't i
don't give a [ __ ] i felt the pain i felt
the pain a little bit on saturday it
bothered me and i thought about it all
day and uh
i was kind of down yeah and i just went
to the ymca and i got back up
i went to the y i [ __ ] uh ate a pot
cookie they got uh socon cookies now
okay remember the the cookie that you
[ __ ] hate yeah
yeah i know i know you know
oh good lord so i went into the wheat
store they had one of those i popped a
quarter of those and
i went to the y did the epileptic oh i
hit the bag for a half hour i rode the
bike for 15 in the beginning and i got
the [ __ ] out of it oh [ __ ]
and uh then yesterday i
i was sitting there wow
i had to do a podcast at 12 for a friend
of mine rafi
as esparza who was that flapper as a
comedian really funny guy
i had to do a podcast so i drove the
girls to church and then i picked them
up
okay and then uh
i said you know what i'm gonna go to
[ __ ] jiu jitsu at one the baby fell
asleep at like 12 35
i put my [ __ ] knee pads on put my
knee pants on i flew over there and it
was packed
really the gym is always dead on sunday
the jujitsu gym oh no i understand that
was packed there was probably
18 people over there ready to roll but
they all had no ghee
uh there was three people with a geese
so i got to roll with them twice and one
guy taught me a couple half
guard uh passes and a couple half guard
[ __ ] uh
sweeps and it was great every like i
said man every time i leave jiu jitsu
it's like somebody gives me a thousand
bucks
because i know i overcame like a big
fear i have like i take my little baby
ass when somebody call him yeah pop papa
man what's up my little brother
what's happening i came out here in the
lift your hour
yeah you're flying back out to montreal
my brother
yeah i'm going to there sometimes
shows tonight so you got you this you
you're up there for three weeks there's
always your feet on the line by the way
if everybody's wondering
you you're everybody mind your business
what was last weekend the last weekend
was the dirty show
last night's dirty show with slayton and
apollo and that's her and then um did
you say slavery
clinton yeah how was it
sorry he's worried about his future
he's really worried did you tell me what
am i supposed to do
did you torture him a little bit
uh i started to torture him but then he
always started he knows me right now
he's like he's like you don't do coco
like uh i tried i was like you know a
little bit
if now you're you know just a pothead
i know now
you know what he tried to friend me on
facebook
me and ralphie were sitting here ralphie
[ __ ] did the podcast and let the cat
out of the bag on the podcast how i used
to torture him and [ __ ] and somebody
else asked me about it how i used to
tell him i put it under his [ __ ] milk
container and
he'd say where the [ __ ] is it i don't
know it's under your milk container
jesus christ my daughter stole it
the first time i went it was so great
when you told them like hey ari sorry uh
ari does a lot of blow he's got a
package coming for him he was friendly
with me he was extra
he looked at me all weird
he was like where are you going like
nothing i just got uh sometimes we're
gonna meet but oh are you going to meet
him later
there's a difference man calm down
you get so into it oh he's uh he's a
great guy man the reason why i want to
have you on today is because
i've been in what's called the conundrum
the last couple weeks uh because you
have uh this is not happening now but
it's going from
the internet to prime time tv on comedy
central
on tv yeah 11 o'clock at night prime
[ __ ] time brother this is a show that
started for five bucks at the [ __ ]
improv back room on a tuesday night the
first one at thursday nights me mark
maron remember we all did that [ __ ]
one show over there
yeah yeah all psychedelics oh
yeah we all that's when i told the pink
floyd thing but it's so weird that
it all started and now it's on a
television and you call me i'm going to
do one of the episodes in september at
the cheetah we're going back to the
cheetah
and it's so weird this this writing uh
this writing [ __ ] uh
process
has just been
i don't know ari this has really changed
me
well it's kind of fun to be like uh
just to sort of think about those things
sometimes i don't even think about those
times until i until i get a topic and
then i start like wondering what
happened i called my high school friend
sometimes i was like hey would i ever
get into it you know
whatever the topic is i would ask
anything happening on my memory and
remind me of stories i'm like oh yeah
oh yeah we stuck that toothbrush up our
ass that's right
whatever it was
it's just fun to
relive those days and stuff and it's so
funny like whenever i do those things i
usually think about it i make little
notes
and then i make calls
i'll try to call people who were around
me at that time and i go remember that
time and they'll go yeah
didn't you [ __ ] whatever like i
called my uncle uh because i wanted to
get the whole funeral thing
you know i called my uncle and we talked
for like an hour and he was like let me
tell you something all my [ __ ] 74
years i never saw a crazier funeral than
your mother's
and that's what happened he goes do you
remember the first night
and i go no and he goes you don't
remember the first night with zarida how
she had the [ __ ] owner by the neck
and three people had to break him apart
and i go
oh my god yeah that's right there was it
was the opening night all white people
came to that one
that was the all-white one like
everybody from the neighborhood came
their parents the kids from the
neighborhood
i was never so embarrassed in my life
because because as a writer didn't go
off on the afternoon one you know they
usually have a two to four viewing
then they have uh uh you know a four to
seven or six to nine
a cuban awake is 24 hours
for five days
because that's how you did them in the
old country you put the body in your
house and people just came to your house
so this is fine
like a [ __ ]
like dictator yeah like in your living
room in the old days when you died there
was no funeral parlors they put you in a
casket and they put you in the living
room and then people came over and they
drank and they and they whatever they
did they pissed on you and they went
[ __ ] home no big deal
so they wanted to he wanted to have that
same cuban feeling in this cuban funeral
parlor it's called rivero funeral parlor
still in north bergen it's a different
owner though the guy made millions and
got the [ __ ] out of it
and i'll never forget that the first day
at the funeral man not the two to four
one but the seven to nine
i'm a young kid i'm still in shock that
my mother died i'm having a conversation
with some kids about basketball
and all of a sudden i'm hearing in
spanish
that means [ __ ] your mother i'm gonna
kill you and [ __ ] and i go in the other
room as the rider's got the [ __ ]
owner
by the throat and there's three people
and she's pointing at him and she's
yelling at him and i go what's going on
and and she told me that she my mother
didn't have the right dress on
and i remember thinking about that going
who gives a [ __ ] she's dead
do you think she's worried about what
dress she's got she's [ __ ] dead
you know but just uh
and i know my uncle saying that there
was a they did like some santoria stuff
the first day at the the funeral i
didn't remember this either and he goes
to the day they buried it they still
hadn't cleaned that water up and that
the water tipped over in the jar in the
limousine and at the limousine drive i
do remember that pulled over and
couldn't drive because the water center
from the santeria water filled yeah the
santeria water had like chicken blood in
it and
all this goat blood and [ __ ] that had
killed all these animals and it was in
there mixed with feathers and [ __ ] and
the [ __ ] thing that you're supposed
to throw in the hole with it and the
thing tipped over and the [ __ ] limo
smelled like ass the limo driver had to
pull over he couldn't drive he kept
puking
this was [ __ ] the funeral from
[ __ ] hell people were drinking people
were doing blow i don't know the first
time they ripped out like a bottle of
pinch because my mother drank pinch so
they ripped out a bottle of pinch which
is like a whiskey and the frina paula
was like guys you cannot drink at my
funeral
here i will lose my license and they've
just looked at them like
you better get back in that [ __ ] room
we're gonna drink
so all these things i got from my uncle
i remembered the i remembered the one
night that was the night that always
stayed with me but
back back to what we're talking about
here it's just amazing ari what you've
done with this because i don't worry
about [ __ ]
i usually when i write a joke i write a
joke and i put it out there whether they
like it or not it's a joke to me
and just by the sound of it you you know
whether you're going to keep it or not
you know yeah uh this is something that
we get to put out one time we really get
the prices exactly one time pretty much
and then you're done and then you're
done you get to practice it a little bit
you know but not really because people
look at your wheel like we're at a
comedy show why are you telling me about
your dead [ __ ] mother
yeah you can work around the
conversation but it gets weird sometimes
yeah i tried doing it the other night
people were like where the [ __ ] are we
going with this [ __ ] joey
so i'm gonna have to have leah
tape me in the [ __ ] here and we'll
send it to you and see what you think
but it's just really weird all right man
it's just uh
i like writing pretty cool isn't it
like [ __ ] 12 people in the audience
with no booze
that's right there's no booze in there
you couldn't bring food in
get booze next door the first two or
three of them we had no booze and then
after that you put a name on it
somebody showed up and you moved it to
the big room and there was no looking
back after that yeah they were getting
mad because the lineups were so good and
they were like why do you have [ __ ]
joey diaz and bill burr
and jim jeffries in this in the little
side room for five dollars i'm like i
don't know two rooms you gave me
you wanna book suckers because you gave
me a small room
i'm not they're gonna do that
yeah let me introduce a big girl
yeah when you write some of these
stories when you're thinking about some
of these stories like your sex ones
do you [ __ ] get [ __ ] up for a few
days like that you did these things like
i always do
yeah sometimes sometimes i just know it
i have trouble signs with an ending like
like uh
like title together
and like you know there's no real
beginning or ending to a story i mean
like like even that funeral it's like it
doesn't begin at the funeral because you
and your mom were
close you know it begins way before so
it says at what point do you start at
what point do you end it
um so cool like learning the process
even watching other comics too you learn
a lot
you know i watched all the series i
watched rogan and i watched uh
uh moshe kashy i watched i don't even
know some of the [ __ ] names come on
and it's really interesting
it's really interesting
the different styles of storytelling
there are also
you have to jason's later than you are
yeah
you know other people cj or whoever sean
patton yeah it's cool it's like there's
no right way some people just do it
however do you go about it and write it
the same way you write jokes
about both of you
like like the same process when you sit
down and write a joke is it the same
like the same way you go and write let's
write a story
because
the point of it isn't to be funny
like in in a way so
i don't know if it's a different process
yeah it's less it's like it's like it's
like uh it's like um
you know annie hall is a comedy but it's
not as many jokes as [ __ ] happy
gilmore okay
you know so it's like it's slower
but um
yeah so you don't think as much for a
comment because there'll be serious
moments and there can be like a plot you
have to do set up you can't just do a
punchline every five seconds
set some stuff up but people will go
with it the first time i saw one really
good was ralphie may i was working the
cover booth in in the or the comedy
store
and uh and it was a shitty night
nobody's doing that well
and uh and rafi may was on time for like
three minutes four minutes he goes you
know what you guys are not an a audience
you're not getting my a jokes i give my
d jokes
and then he started doing some story
about the first time i met sam kennison
i want some content when he was a 17
year old
and tennessee was doing key bumps in
front of him and his 17 year old like
what the [ __ ] he didn't know what was
happening and man i'll tell you you can
watch when i cover everybody was
on the edge of their seat
you know like interested in what he was
saying it might not have been like
as funny as ralph usually is like punch
punch punch but man it was interesting
you get everyone's attention in a
certain way kid when pig did that that
cd she did it was all just a story about
getting cancer and figuring that out
and she kept going like oh sorry i'll
get back to jokes and people in the
audience were like no don't this is fine
like this
yeah it's like a slower more like
methodical
way of being
it's kind of cool to surprise you too so
bird once i saw him like talking about
something on stage and then he got to
some people about his childhood and he
was like yeah me and john smith and
bill whatever
whatever we're diving down this other
guy mike oh yeah and he goes like oh
yeah mike man i couldn't thought that
guy in like 20 years
i mean like he remembers on stage and
it's like oh it's [ __ ] nice moments
like that it's very interesting to see
the person livid
see you could tell a story anybody could
tell a story but right there when you're
talking about bill burke he got a moment
where he lived it
yeah exactly this that story i told
about the bronx there was a few minutes
on stage i didn't see an audience
i got i can't lie to you
i was on a street corner
just telling the story
like i lost the audience i had i was
having so much fun
you know when you tell a story and
people listen let me tell you what the
best thing about being a comic is when
you relieve the pressure off yourself
that they have to laugh
okay sometimes a story the story is
funny it becomes funny the story is just
funny in the story you'll find the
comedy but the best thing for a comic is
when i come to you ari and go hey listen
this ten minutes you gotta do don't be
funny
watch what happens to a comedian
it changes you yeah i'm not we're not so
addicted to it plus stuff comments or
comments or you're not going to lose the
crowd at any moment if you're not funny
yes when we're coming listen when you're
a comic
the first eight or nine years you're
striving to be funny yeah the first time
i got in the belly room
and i did a stupid testicle testament on
the belly room
oh yeah i remember that
about that 99 i did three hours
three hours
and i talked to 11 because every time i
said okay guys i gotta go they go no
more
and we drink and that's the night you
ever hear rogan talk about joey
something happened to you that you
weren't very fair and then all of a
sudden you got [ __ ] that was the
night
when i realized that you could take the
pressure off yourself
there's a certain pressure we don't know
it's there as a comedian
until you're too yeah when you let it go
there's a confidence that comes out and
when you pull that
switch
your life will change lee it's like a
tongue in the ass it's like a chick that
takes her tongue for the first time you
don't even know that's done a chick
usually just sucks your dick and licks
your nuts and then you jerk off and she
giggles and she gets a towel but then
you meet a dirty [ __ ] [ __ ] who's
sucking that [ __ ] helmet and then
licks your balls and while she's licking
your balls every [ __ ] hair in your
body is popped up your ass and all of a
sudden she takes that tongue and just
wiggles it in your [ __ ] and keeps
jerking you off you've never had that
feeling before in your life you get
dizzy you get anxiety you don't know
what to do and then you just fart come
and it's all over it's a new experience
this
is the new experience as a comedian it
really uh and it's fun to explain
that's why i wanted you to call this
morning ahri because there's a lot of
comics that listen to this and they're
like we don't know how you become a
storyteller this is it
take the pressure off yeah well
the thing is everybody's got stories
everybody tell stories at parties you
know by the time you and john [ __ ]
you know almost thrown out of
whatever from
fenway or something like that and it's
just like how do you tell it this is how
interesting you tell all these comments
but they're just good speakers
they tell these stories already if they
get loose
if they get natural about it like you
said and don't worry about laughs then
it becomes sort of magical
is it scary the first like two minutes
of it when you're not getting laughs
because like everyone's brutal
everyone's laughs per minute
brutal yeah
yeah you're not used to it you know you
don't really study because that's like
30 40 seconds you don't get to laugh you
go i better make a funny face or
something brutal you have you and you
have to keep peddling and believing in
your material you have to keep believing
in your story just believe in your story
and then cloak i love getting stoned
before i go up there but not stone
stoned like [ __ ] stone so i take
away that fear
that little fear that you have so once
i'm up there
it's like anything else that first
minute is brutal i'm sure if you watch
any of those things that first minute
for me is brutal
but once i get a little flame i'm off
and running
once i got a little flame i'm off and
running uh and that's where it picks up
like the fear gets out of the way i
don't give a [ __ ] if you laugh yeah
if it gives you a couple laughs too a
couple laughs like cool now i'm
comfortable now you know they're just
like it's our giving audience and you
get comfortable like cool it'll be fine
you're not worried about bombing because
already into it
once you tell a story
once you tell that story
when you and you eliminate the laughter
it takes the feeling of bombing
it makes it less because you control
that
now you learn also that you control your
laughter
that you control your audience that's
the other power about storytelling that
once they're not getting laughs and
you're controlling them oh my god oh my
god are you you're fidel castro europe
you're a present
that's a presence
i thought dice wants to do this at the
or2 and he goes on
and uh it's when he wasn't smoking but
he was still he was still chewing
cigarettes you know it was like put in
his mouth so he came up he puts his
drink on the on the uh on the
stool
and then he takes his he didn't say a
word just takes his um
cigarette pack out he taps it on the
microphone a little bit
and he like packs him down then he takes
his jacket off and he picks up his
strength from the stool takes a drink
puts it back down
goes over the microphone just test
goes i make a lot of tests all right
good and he just keeps watching he says
one word for about a minute and a half
and then he goes see i love these comics
they get up here
they don't get to laugh for this long
they'd be terrified
they'd be in the corner shiver it
because me no i know how this is going
to end
but he was right he had him all laughing
and as soon as he wanted to they got him
all out rude up to him rejected him
how lucky were we
to get to see dice come up every night
you know i hear these comics and oh
dice used to bump up for two hours and
[ __ ] let me tell you something i learned
more in those two it was like going to a
college course
when you saw dice perform on sunday
nights and stuff it really was sunday
nights it was he would be someone with
him and rock and [ __ ] and damon would
all come down on [ __ ] sunday night
just ran it for no no money you got him
free they got him before nine
it was something it was like
i i can't even
yeah i was hosting i was hosting i used
to call them and tell them please come
down here
because [ __ ] somebody's going to be
there on the list and i want to bump
them
so i would make that
see listen i would get there at seven
and i would host that the first i would
host i would hang out for the first show
then the second show i knew don barris
always wanted to host
so chewie would come i'd borrow a 20 or
two i'd pick up two packages of coke
dice would shake over chris rock would
show up i'd go there i'd do my 10
minutes bring dice up i knew dice was
going to do 40. i go out there tell don
bearer's done you got it from here and i
leave and they paid me 25 [ __ ] bucks
but i got an education i got the biggest
[ __ ] education i remember one sunday
night andrew was up there and he was
going off
he was going off
and there was these two chinese guys in
the front row and he just [ __ ] oh i
found him like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you don't even know what i'm talking
about do you
he's talking about kung fu the tv show
and afterward he goes all right don't
worry about it and he walks away he goes
look
he goes look at them they're over there
smiling they're going to call their
cousins on the phone tomorrow when i eat
chinese food i'm going to [ __ ] blood for
three weeks these [ __ ] chicks they'll
do anything to your [ __ ] food they'll
spit in your food anyway and they were
laughing they were [ __ ] loving it you
know just to see somebody of you making
fun of them and you're dying and you're
like i can't wait to be able to do that
and then you go up and try it and it
works
that's what dice was dice was like going
to jiu jitsu class
you learned something and then when you
spa you went and [ __ ] did it it was
amazing what i learned from him
chris rock
richard jenny
damon wayne i'll be out there i learned
from you watching you you and paulie
actually were the two most
the two most like yourself on stage and
off stage
you know how everybody else is like yeah
you and paul could probably grow up you
know he's doing it since he was [ __ ]
like that's right that's right so
yeah it was not like he was good but he
was the most like himself you and him
two of you like you'd be talking to
either one of you backstage and then you
go on stage it's the same exact person
there's no like a little bit stylized
the same exact person
because i'm on stage now
but
let me finish my conversation up there
i would watch you you would look at that
list you had to bring up
comments and you would look at the list
of the employees or who the next pop-in
is and you would [ __ ] get stuck in a
coke days and you would move your hands
open and shut we were like why like five
fingers wide open and shut over and over
again it's opening and shutting i'm
opening i'm just trying to do whatever
your bits are pretending like you were
looking at the list to use next you look
at the list for 10 minutes while you
were talking opening and shutting your
hand and then eventually just go coming
up next
i'm gonna ask you the next person
right now those open mics that were the
most fun you know
people have no idea how much fun an open
mic is listen sometimes it's great to go
see david tell it's great to go see joe
rogan it's great to go see louis ck you
know
uh yeah but sometimes guys you know
you're not doing nothing on a monday
it's a shitty baseball game tuesday
night go to your local [ __ ] open mic
smoke a joint in the car go in it's
always cheap beers
always cheap you know i don't even think
they have a two-drink minimum on an open
mic you know you go you need no cover
charge
just go down there and watch a comic and
it's early developments
it's no different than what you people
were doing in your whatever job you were
[ __ ] doing in the beginning
it's just comics [ __ ] awkward as [ __ ]
you know
but it's the same reason why i've stuck
it out with jiu jitsu i go to jiu-jitsu
every day ari to get beat up yesterday i
was in the bottom and half guard the
whole [ __ ] day getting beat up i
couldn't sweep anybody finally i pulled
this purple belt though it'll come in
though you got to give me some [ __ ]
sweeps from the bottom but ari i keep
going
because of comedy
because i know that someday it's gonna
come all together
and i'm gonna sweep the [ __ ] get
on top of them and get them in an
american and this lights [ __ ] out you
follow me yeah right now it's just a
dream it's just a dream for me to sweep
somebody get on top and secure my
position and get an american that's my
dream and eventually i hate it it might
not be today ari maybe in two [ __ ]
you'll nail it you'll hit it i'll nail
just because i'll get pissed off man
and this is it this is this is comedy
you know this storytelling element that
you've
you're about to blow up right now and
i'm very thankful to you for doing this
this is a different element of our game
that nobody ever thought of
but as a young kid well it's all
different you have you got one-liners
that's a part of it too you got you got
you know
rants off and you got improvised
part of it you've got so many different
styles of comedy but one of them that
you know a lot of times i go into a town
at a young kind of go say hey man i
listen to the podcast
and i get impressed
those are the people that really make me
feel like i'm doing my job because
i wish i had somebody that i could
listen to when i was getting in my first
two years of stand-up
you know tommy easton he was at the show
uh great kid open mic always sends me
notes about what he's doing that was me
20 years ago
i think the comic i leaps on to is todd
jordan i'd call him every day and go
todd you're not going to believe this
what what'd you do last night seven
minutes whoop dee
call hbo you know
but you're so [ __ ] excited and i'm
this you know so i want comics to know
that at some point one night close your
eyes and go i'm not gonna be funny
tonight i'm just gonna go up there and
tell a story about my dog getting sick
in the back of the [ __ ] car on the
way to atlantic city
tell the [ __ ] story and just believe
in it stick to your guns don't worry
about the laughter you know if you've
ever watched uh you know our our friend
greg jackson
you know greg jackson i think it's greg
jackson tell his fighters
that he wants the audience to boo
because that means you're doing your job
you want the audience what to do like
there's a lot of fighters that'll go in
there and they'll just hold their
position
they'll just sit there and make him get
for range and he goes he doesn't care if
they boo
he doesn't care that that's what you're
working your game you believe in your
game that much dana white don't like to
hear that [ __ ]
then white don't want to hear that [ __ ]
but that mean like rashad evans would
say that he wanted you to do that
because that means you were doing your
job
it's the same early times can't do it
that's insecure it can't go 30 seconds
i'm telling you
if you're a year and a half comic and
you do this that's the fastest way of
getting funny
because that was the launch of me you
know somebody was telling me last week a
way to to really get your cardio going
is to get a heart
thing to check your heart and go to your
simplest rate when you get up out of bed
what your heart rate is at that point
and do lift your legs 30 day 30 times
like a like a marching band type thing
and then stop and don't do it again
until you get your heart rate down to
the bottom to where it was again that's
the same thing you know that's how you
make your cardio get better this is how
you improve your economy is by adding
storytelling to your game believing in
your story that much that it's going to
lead them intrigued and then you could
still do five minutes of comedy at the
end of your set
you're following me you still don't end
like if you put it together yeah all
right and i'll do this stuff now you
could really [ __ ] you follow me so
it's it's it's a great exercise ahri
i'm very proud you know 20 years from
now people are going to be sitting you
know i started storytelling after i
watched that's not happening episode 6
with ari and [ __ ] big j okason and
[ __ ] you know that's what's going to
happen
that's my favorite part is that people
get good clips out of it that you and
jay and whoever else rogan and you know
tj and sean patton and sakura they all
get like good clips out of it they can
like people enjoy you know like other
comics and a chance i'm gonna tell you
something i like i like that part i hate
watching myself i definitely hate
listening to myself i hate taping myself
i'm not one of those people beside this
longest yard thing that adam sandlin
those people sent me i don't really have
posters or pictures i'm like looking at
myself
there's only one thing in
24 years i'm very proud of that's on
youtube i mean i have some good stuff on
youtube
but the most proudest is the second
story
the one about my mother and the taxi cab
because yeah i'm gonna tell you
something
i'm gonna tell you something and i know
rogan's does it i know rogan has
mentioned it and you guys know it every
time i go on stage i forget two or three
good jokes
and if i do that three or four times i
forget the [ __ ] joke till i find it
in an old notebook
that storyteller was this closest i ever
got to what i wrote in my life
that was the closest i ever came except
for a few faux pas
with [ __ ] carrie
and that
but let me tell you why i threw the
carry liner because that was the last
thing i watched on tv and it was in my
psyche
so in your head so my stand-up already
knows to get something out that i
disagree with just to get it out like my
body already knows that they talk about
muscle memory
in my muscle i know that if something is
bothering me i gotta get it on the stage
and i didn't think about that until a
week later when you released i go why
did i [ __ ] say it on stage
why would i stop the [ __ ] story to
say [ __ ] they're releasing carrie on
stage because it was in the back of my
mind that driving the 101 i was furious
that they had remade [ __ ] carry
that's how [ __ ] up we are as comedians
people that's the first team that's
actually a thing we did when we talked
about we were like finishing them we
were editing them we didn't edit much
but if somebody just went off on some
side things didn't go anywhere it wasn't
funny but they were talking about that
one they were like we got to chop these
down i was like why why they're for the
internet we're not going to have them 30
seconds so who cares if there's seven
minutes or 15 minutes i'm like we can't
do it i'm like why and they're like look
some parts don't involve the story and
they go what about that part where
george diaz talks about carrie that's
not involved we can just take that out
and i was like no that's the part that
makes it breathe
that's the part where comedy is just
[ __ ] relaxing leave that part in
leave it in it was funny and it [ __ ]
slows everything down so you're not in
the [ __ ] rush to get to you know top
at top and punchline punch on punchline
just let it go let it breathe and
they're like all right
and that's what i like about them the
[ __ ] all the stories breathe you know
there's a rush so in the middle of my
ranting this [ __ ] thing came out
about carrie that had been burning my
soul on the 101 for the last 20 [ __ ]
minutes and that's how i know that this
thing we do
is real ari that's when i realized after
24 [ __ ] years
that what i do is real when i see
something that bothers me not to be on
stage if i think something's comical or
you know me [ __ ] in that cup three weeks
ago i had a [ __ ] in a cup of the doctor
and here's the funny thing
they sent me a report back and told my
[ __ ] was normal
it's not normal it's in a cup and they
taste
normal
i had to take like a little [ __ ]
stick and [ __ ] in the toilet and then
take the [ __ ] out of the stick and put
in this piece of paper and close it the
[ __ ] would work as the glue
and i had to do that three different
shits in one [ __ ] day and i only took
two big ones so i had to wait till like
two in the morning i pushed out this
little [ __ ] my intestine almost [ __ ]
popped out and had a scrape and put it
in and i said to myself wow i sent those
three pieces of [ __ ] i've never heard
back from my doctor or not about a week
long i get this thing from you you see a
leg oh yo here we go
i open it up and there it is your [ __ ]
results are [ __ ] normal
how [ __ ] strong am i so this montreal
this week
when when will your show start
uh my show starts tonight monday tuesday
wednesday thursday at cleopatra this
training strip club that's where we got
the idea to the strip club from this
montreal montreal comedy festival okay
they put us in the strip club and i was
worried about it i thought they were
doing it just because it was like it was
all sex stories i thought they were just
trying to make it a scene but
when i got up there it was cool looking
i mean you walk up these steps and these
old pictures of
strippers they're like faded and black
and white and you just start feeling
more like a degenerate and then when
people get on stage and they tell their
story like you don't give a [ __ ] however
dark they get you don't give a [ __ ]
i gotta be honest man i'm happy with the
crowds that come now the crowd know what
it is we did one we did one in brooklyn
at uh at union hall
um
now like a month ago and d.c benny was
telling some story about getting
molested when he was little and the
crowd was roaring with laughter there
was no like oh no this is terrible it's
like you could all tell they were like
look you seem cool with it now so we're
gonna laugh with you
you know
he was like man that was the greatest
audience i've ever done for that one one
of those things like yeah the
degenerates they know the deal
and they're cool
so anyway yeah tonight through thursday
at midnight uh hahaha.com if you're on
if you're if you're in montreal and then
yeah that's that's it until until we
tape them september 9. and we're going
september 9th again at the cheetah right
two shows a night actually yeah with the
two shows and then we're going ninth and
the fifteenth so
tuesday and then monday after that
um
i'm available for both of them tarzan so
whatever you need i'm showing up one
last question for you you got another
minute
yeah i always say detail too i got a
show in brooklyn on august 21st at the
bell house and if you go to my it's me
doing an hour in new york so it's the
only island i'm going to do in new york
so come out 15 bucks
i got to ask you an example because i'm
i'm sitting with two of my best brothers
here
you're both jewish you're open to israel
you're both
yeah no no it's not it's not a bash due
time you know i don't play that [ __ ] i
got an email the other day i got a
twitter that lee is here
say hello lee hey no yeah okay lee read
it you know and i was really upset about
the guys like on monday you got to talk
on the podcast
about what's going on over there let the
world know what's going on over there
what the [ __ ] is going on over there
tell me what the [ __ ] this guy was
talking about
does anybody know or am i [ __ ]
[ __ ] here i don't know what he's
talking about well i don't know
yeah i don't know if it's the same for
you ari
but anyone who's mad like that is
usually against israel and i don't know
if they're pro-palestine but they're
definitely anti-israel i
it's close to segregation it's close to
the way it wasn't in south africa but
it's not the same
because the only reason they're they're
they're putting them you know at
checkpoints like that because they're
smuggling you know guns them but the
only reason they stop
ambulances
they used to let ambulances go right
through the checkpoint so like look it's
dangerous go through but then the
[ __ ] palestinians start smuggling
[ __ ] bombs on an ambulance and i was
like well now we gotta [ __ ] check
these two yeah and i don't know
the little kids who have no homes now
there's a little girl a little
six-year-old girl i'm sure somewhere in
the house and guys are the west bank
whose house is blown up
and she didn't do anything she didn't do
anything to anybody but now she's got no
home
but she didn't do anything like well
these palestinians didn't like no that's
just one person who didn't do anything
to anybody and now she's [ __ ] out of a
home
but at the same time
i heard somebody say it like this if one
side just laid down their guns and said
we're not gonna fight anymore
do whatever you do we're not gonna fight
anymore
if the arabs did that what would the
jews do
they'd probably stop fighting too and if
the jews did that what would the arabs
do they'd wipe the jews the [ __ ] out
yeah i mean and it's because i just got
one last night i got some guy yelling at
me saying i was racist he's not
listening anymore
he's yelling me i'm like dude i'm not
israeli i don't know what you're talking
about why are you why are you honest
really
well i retweeted i stand with israel i i
reached the thing that got that guy mad
was i retweeted something i stand with
israel or something
uh
i obviously there's people who aren't
involved it's just there's terrorists
there's terrorists there and it's
condensed so it seems like a lot
obviously there's some people who don't
deserve there's some people who don't
deserve what's happening to them
probably the majority of palestinians
are pretty nice
but when you have
terrorists who are
they're hiding by schools all terrorists
do this not just palestine they hide by
schools so if a bomb goes there they
blow up the school and they seem like
[ __ ]
but if mexico or canada or cuba like i
think about this the other day people
like well mexico is never gonna send a
bomb if cuba was sending bombs at miami
20 30 times a day they lost 100 rockets
in two days they lost 100 rockets in two
days yeah so if they're like hey guys
you can't do it you can't launch rockets
into our country right every other
country in the world will go in there
america what israel does is they send
ground troops in and they [ __ ]
leave for the place like get out we're
bombing this building on this day
please leave yeah i try to give people a
chance to get out and obviously for me
you don't do that yeah i'm sure you are
joe you lived there for a while i was
only there for six months
when i came back if this was going on i
would have been super racist on here
against just because you talked to
people who like had that [ __ ] happen to
them with the bombs and stuff and
since i've been back i'm a little bit
less anti-palestinian
but it's just yeah yeah they don't have
it easy but it's like it's goes both
ways
the [ __ ] [ __ ] they're just they hate
each other
yeah that's what it comes down to
and you can't negotiate and israel is
probably doing once a long time that i
realize
they say like if if let's say somebody
invades another country or texas from
taking over from mexico or whatever at
some point you make a peace treaty it's
like all right we'll give you this land
you give us this land and we'll
compromise
but
what their deal is they were they're
commanded by god to wipe the jews out
so how are you going to compromise on
that how are you going to make a peace
treaty on that level because well we're
still commanded by god to wipe you out
so you can't negotiate that away
right and after terms yeah i mean when
you see like the the propaganda they're
showing to like their six-year-olds
about jews drain the blood of of arabs
to make our bread
like it's like oh yeah
that's from the drums oh yeah yeah and i
i don't know where the video was i
remember watching when i was there but
the thing that i don't think enough
people i mean i'm sure israel is doing
stuff i'm sure the same thing that
america does [ __ ] up [ __ ] during war
with like the
whatever that prison was in afghanistan
and iraq or iraq and they do of course
because their majors hate the enemy
right it serves people so they'll piss
on each other and future like that
yeah so i mean israel is doing some [ __ ]
but it's just i don't know for me
if you're sending bombs though if anyone
was if anyone sent one bomb to america
we'd be invading their country
so it's yeah well although all cuba
there was a planet bomb yeah the point
one
and we haven't been talking tall from 50
years
when am i gonna see you [ __ ]
what am i gonna see you um
i'll be there for a couple days i think
august like august like
four fifths oh my god six
yeah i'm doing my colonoscopy august 4th
there's no [ __ ] podcast august fourth
till nighttime they're sticking a tube
up my ass at six a.m lee's driving me at
six and my wife's picking me up at 10
30. ari i love you [ __ ]
be safe
thanks for coming and playing thank you
see i gave you the jew minute see
nobody gives it
i didn't say a word when two israeli
jews are talking [ __ ] gentiles shut
their [ __ ] mouths you understand me
if i'm i'm telling you the [ __ ] rule
[ __ ] when two jews are talking
shut your [ __ ] mouth i love you ari
have a great day
oh my god the church of what's happening
now [ __ ] monday july 21st the
world is yours let me give some shout
outs to my main [ __ ] jeremy
turtle classen josh costa alex chavez my
main man rob kulesh
lady jay looking better than ever
gomez and escondido
and shabu shib whatever your [ __ ]
name is
right here making it happen over here in
the [ __ ] church i'm [ __ ] stoned
yeah me too i tell you a little cheap
but you works out perfect you had a lot
more than i did but sure you know how i
do it i don't [ __ ] i wasn't gonna
bring that up today because i got a
this guy was pissed at me what who gives
a [ __ ] hey listen i gotta explore every
[ __ ] avenue this is a church of
what's happening i'm not here to visit
somebody and most people i don't want
somebody pissed at me or uh him let's
lee give his [ __ ] point of view and
if you people get pissed off you know a
model here if you can't take a joke take
a [ __ ] taxi [ __ ] sucker and it's it's
just it's not an arab thing and it's not
a muslim thing it's a it's a terrorist
thing so i'm no i mean that's someone
called me racist i was like what could i
possibly have said that was racist like
maybe we talked about that no no some
people uh you know they wake up in the
mornings and they understand things
wrong
because i [ __ ] get it i sometimes i
get [ __ ] i take something the wrong
way too when i wake up on the wrong side
of the bed you never know what
somebody's thinking you don't want to
wake up on the wrong side of the bed get
new mood from [ __ ] on it that's what
who's who's better than uncle joe look
at that transition i come [ __ ]
prepared with two guns bullets and a
[ __ ] grenade in my [ __ ] that's how
i show up you understand me on it go to
honor.com this is the way to [ __ ] do
it you people are hitting me up oh joey
you're on fire you know why because i
started back on the alpha brain on
[ __ ] saturday i'm back [ __ ] dirty
day [ __ ] run i'm gonna write some
comedy i'm gonna get the story down
ferrari this is not happening i'm gonna
lose some weight i'm home the month of
august this is what i'm doing what the
[ __ ] i gotta go to paducah kentucky to
visit the family
in august i can't wait
my main man i got some [ __ ] dude my
main man in paducah is trying to get me
a knight oh there's a little comedy you
know i'm saying people drive down from
cincy i'll keep the prices low we'll
hang out we'll smoke some dope you know
how we do it [ __ ] anyway talking
about it how the [ __ ] do we get on this
[ __ ] i don't know honest.com the best
this is not a vitamin this is not a
supplement this is a complete different
[ __ ] level whether it's the alpha
brain whether it's the hemp forest
protein shake
whether it's just the new uh the strong
bone whether it's the [ __ ] shroom
tech which i took two of those off and i
went there and i rolled yesterday and i
got my ass kicked
try it out they got kettlebells they got
ropes they got [ __ ] battle ropes they
got [ __ ] things you swing up in the
air like a hula hoop
all that stuff go there i don't care
what you look at make you you want your
life to be better you want you you want
to [ __ ] be sharp
[ __ ] it you know i smoke dope like a
[ __ ] my mind's always [ __ ]
going always
that's the alpha brain why [ __ ] around
go to honor.com go to joey dears get 10
percent off your order get signed in get
emails get on the side stay on it
program do yourself a favor this ain't
for [ __ ] pushovers if you try the
alpha brain there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee why don't you want the product
you don't do it one time only all right
go to joeydiaz.net get yourself a d
patch at the same time
go to on it press in church church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off your honor
product again what do i got to do here
what the [ __ ] do we got to do here i got
to stand up and jump in up and down
people listen
tv blows in the summer it blows it
[ __ ] blows they put on the worst [ __ ]
catch up on your television shows catch
up on movies catch up on kids shows why
[ __ ] around huluplus.com
they do not [ __ ] around lee what are the
shows they have my wife lives on hulu
plus i think she's watching house of
cards or some [ __ ] on that
every week is something different the
other day she goes you know what why are
we messing around the kids show that we
like the [ __ ] is on hulu plus hulu
plus is tremendous 7.99 a month you get
kids shows documentary shows tv shows
you know the today what is it the daily
show you know that the one they have
they have the criterion collection like
a whole bunch of cool movies plus they
got original programming right yeah oh
yeah there's a bunch of it i'm telling
you right now stop [ __ ] around go to
huluplus.com why waste your time
7.99 a month eight dollars to get
[ __ ] pb every show
rock it watch it when you want where you
want it works on ipads any [ __ ]
device that streams
there you [ __ ] have it you stick your
[ __ ] finger in a socket no stream on
your palm or your hand
hulu plus or delivery you understand me
go to huluplus.com and press in joey
joey in the box huluplus.com and press
what joey in the box 7.99 a month deal
but you're going joey that's the same i
get from the commercial yeah you don't
get two weeks for free from the [ __ ]
commercial suck my dick and call me
shorty i was born in 1940 bam two weeks
for free not one week not one day two
weeks two weeks two weeks huluplus.com
today go there right now today stop with
this other [ __ ] you're wasting your
[ __ ] time you got a [ __ ] device
ipad roku oh cool look who
you are television [ __ ] it'll work
for you all right stop messing around
7.99 a month but what i'm gonna do is
give you two weeks for free when was the
last time somebody licked your nuts for
two weeks for free until you gave them a
check bam go to hulupus.com and press in
jelly who the [ __ ] do you think you're
dealing with [ __ ] you want to look
good
dollarshaveclub.com your balls smell
good your [ __ ] smells good they got
the wipes what else they got one of my
charlie's warm-up covers
dr covers shave butter they got the
pre-fucking shave but the most expensive
the
most expensive one i'm getting
what but the most the best thing about
the dollar shave program is it's a
dollar a month that's right joey a
dollar a month six dollars a month well
how much nine dollars nine dollars a
month nine dollars a month gets you four
raises double blade razors with dialog
strip sent to your house nice you look
like [ __ ] bridget bardo's [ __ ] in
66. the six dollar plan gets you four
razors sent the owls double blades
tremendous no aloe strip you rubbed it
on your own time and the [ __ ] what
dollar plan gets you one blade it's
stupid
what extra shot you could took those
things apart and [ __ ] cut the fat off
your toe you know what i'm saying you
can stab a puerto rican with it that's
how they roll oh over that dollar shave
well the handle is like a weapon and the
[ __ ] handle is like a weapon you get
two of them
and put a [ __ ] chain in between those
handles tremendous every morning i shave
with my dollar shave club i get four of
them sent to my house tremendous razors
you don't gotta stand online like some
[ __ ] mooc at some place behind some
guy that stinks like dick you don't
gotta stand instead of lemon behind some
guy thinks his day's gonna be made
playing the [ __ ] lottery ever get
behind one of those [ __ ] they get oh
yeah let me get 609 let me get a
scratchy guy you're a [ __ ] stiff it's
not happening not today you got a better
chance of jumping off a [ __ ] bridge
and eaten by a shark that hit the
[ __ ] lottery get the [ __ ] out of here
dollar shave club a dollar six dollars
or nine dollars correct correct deliver
straight to your house you don't have to
leave the [ __ ] house go to the dollar
shave club boxing and joeydears.net or
go to dollarshaveclub.com and press in
church church chu rch in a box and get
your [ __ ] razor sent to your house
starting today also
my main man my main man escape
podtank.com for all your sensory
deprivation needs they got tremendous
tank just the tank model will give you
150 off if you mention me you get
another deuce and a half off they'll
deliver it to your house whether it's
residential commercial whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do you want people coming
over your house jumping up and down
whacking off in your tub you can charge
by the hour you want to jump in there
yourself and scratch your nuts and sniff
your fingers underwater that's up to you
too call my man on the 800 line go to
escape podtank.com escape by tank.com
take a look at all their [ __ ] tanks
all the options they have financing is
available you understand me mention the
church joey diaz the flying jew
uh he hates yom's whatever the [ __ ] you
want to talk about
you get 250 off what the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with here little tony
bennett he's up the mood here what the
[ __ ] lee you're slipping it's july 21st
bruce lee's been dead for 41 years what
the [ __ ] have you done with your life
[ __ ] wake up go out there stab a
[ __ ]
somebody
with me
when you were saying the hulu ad and he
said he could plug your
finger into a wall and watching your
hand i just kept thinking why doesn't he
have the wireless model i thought like
why would he stop the plug-in model if
it's on here i'm gonna get this double
and shut them up your [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's not brought to you by
andrew i love you [ __ ] this is a
beautiful little
devil's boxing i'm gonna have this
forever in my house and i forget this
[ __ ] what's up [ __ ] what are you
gonna do the rest of the day i got steve
simony coming right after you and then i
got
texas uh chainsaw massacre one and two
with rick ramos tonight
uh changed change from massacre one two
what the [ __ ] he thinking what am i
gonna do with that [ __ ] thing
he's gonna make you sit through horror
let's say no you don't like hara you're
gonna [ __ ] cry you're gonna call me
18 times pop are they really scary i
wasn't they doing that texas chainsaw
massachusetts i know it's great but it's
[ __ ] greasy but they're singing
around dancing to a balcony
table
you're gonna call me 18 times papa come
over
hug me did you hear from your dad
yesterday yeah he talked on the way home
how's he doing he's doing great and
how's your mom everybody good in the
family brother yeah you miss him you
call him every day you call your mom
every day you tell her you love her yeah
talk to her a few times a week 26 years
ago yesterday she was spitting out that
little jew monkey
she unleashed you on the [ __ ] world
at 10 20 p.m like biggie and [ __ ]
respect you know what i'm saying you bad
[ __ ] all right everything's
going good you had a nice time in vegas
i had a nice time yeah you were there it
was fun that [ __ ] jambalaya was
i
terrible
wasn't
it would taste like [ __ ] it didn't
look like you liked me you know i took a
[ __ ] a three foot [ __ ] when i got it so
it's hysterical when i go on the road i
don't [ __ ] i [ __ ] just the overflow
the all right what's the overflowing my
[ __ ] in my gut i [ __ ] out when i get
home after i land i mess around i talk
to my wife i play with the baby
they come to a point where i take
everything comes out and i just go
straight in the shower i don't take a
shower for that it's like a and there's
[ __ ] everywhere my face my fingers my
legs
yeah when you're telling that to ari i
just imagined
you
kneeling down at your toilet with a
[ __ ] stick and i was like
if there were only cameras here i did i
had to turn around with the [ __ ]
camera and i had to put the stick in the
paper perfectly and i had to throw the
stick away
and the funny thing was they sent me
sticks and i lost them so i had to go to
a starbucks one of those coffee places
and steal those [ __ ] stairs oh my
good ones you know how i rolled doug
never a dull moment any of the
colonoscopy coming up august 4th are you
worried about it no my dad says it's not
that bad no it's not bad at all i gotta
just drink uh
i got what i'm gonna do is the week
leading up to it i'm really gonna fluid
up my diet okay i'm gonna just start by
like just you know uh soup juicing and
juices and
you know all that [ __ ] just a lot of
juices
maybe i'll lose some [ __ ] weight you
never know for seven days yeah and then
leading up to it is
sunday so i'm home
all day so you have to drink this white
powdered chocolate yeah and he cleans
everything the bubble gum all those
years of bubble gums i stuck up my
[ __ ] swallow i'm gonna blow a big
when they stick that can on my ass and
that bubble blows up inside of me i
might not make it back from a [ __ ]
colonoscopy
god forbid not what what the [ __ ] we
gotta do to the church every day we
gotta keep the tradition going we gotta
keep some [ __ ] balls in your ass so
i'm talking which
is it i got pretty stoned yesterday you
know i get stoned on the lord's day i
like it i have to yeah
and everything i i got pretty high last
night before i went to bed
and i was in the living room and demi
came in and soup bag came in
and harry came in
and ally was there
and then fidel came in so here i am
sitting alone with my five cats
and they're like three feet away from
each other but they're all surrounding
me they're waiting for me to make my
move like that
i turned the tv off and i'm just sitting
there watching you know
and i've realized the journey they've
taken with me you know these cats were
with me
on on a schrader
when we lived in a little room you know
one room apartment we our bedroom was a
closet
we put a twin bed in the closet and we
had my sleep apnea machine and a tv in
there
then we had the living room we had the
big i mean we were like white trash in
this apartment we're like puerto ricans
you know
but these cats were there with me you
know they and we always fed them
even when i was my brokest i always
found time for fancy feast or
the science diet or boat if i ate out
i'd bring them sushi you know i'd always
get fish for them you know my cats eat
shrimp if i eat [ __ ] uh like last
night i ate salmon
i eat three quarters the rest of them
goes to them yeah you know i love my
cats my cats are part of me
my animals are part of me you know when
i get home now i'm looking at the clock
because every day milly gets walked in
the morning you know millie the german
shepherd oh yeah people so i go over and
i give millie a hug that's part of my
week that's my life you know i love my
animals they make me feel better about
myself i don't know why we don't know
why nobody knows why you wanted to adopt
a dog i don't know they're great they're
just great animals are [ __ ] great and
then you know there's some mornings when
i wake up and i wake up a little unsure
about myself i'm a little insecure
you know some days you just don't have
it you know you don't [ __ ] have it
every day you know but i tell you what
sometimes i stumb once i take a piss i
brush my teeth you know i
i put the coffee on and i turn around
i'm still out of it but i look down i
almost kicked one get the [ __ ] out of
the way in the middle of all that
they're there to scree me
so i get on my hands and knees and i pet
one and run around when you pet one the
other one jumps on the line and then the
other one flips on his back because he
wants more attention and right away i'm
laughing yeah which means
they gave me they did something they
gave me an action a reaction you know
they love
you know the harry doesn't like when you
touch your stomach so he'll let you
touch it for like two minutes then he
gets pissed his back really
yeah and harry's a [ __ ] sweetheart
yeah harry has no mouths at all he just
doesn't like his stomach touch and i was
watching one of those animal planet
shows what the cat doesn't like touched
and it's his belly they don't like me
too much when they fight so i always
thought it was behind their tail you
know
but i'm sitting there last night this is
a story a lot of people don't know about
me i'm sitting there last night and it's
just something
you know i was telling terry we're going
back to see her parents like you know
terry i've lived my life if the [ __ ]
plane goes down you get 250 thousand
dollars
that's the bottom line
that's that's life guys
and i go you know your grandparents i
mean your parents if they fly here the
plane goes down you get 250 but mercy
dies we lose mercy you know i was just
talking to him about 40
and i was looking at that and last night
i was thinking myself what if
you know 50 what if i passed in five
years you know
who would take care of my cats
who would like if something happened to
me and terry
who would take care of the cat yeah i'm
concerned about mercy
but i also all those cats that
commitment you know when i was 15 before
my mother died that summer i got a dog
yeah his name was i named him crystal
because i used to be into crystal thc
i had to do it was just [ __ ] gorilla
biscuits it's angel dust
so me and my friends would get high on
the weekends on crystal and also i got
this dog he was white
and he had like yellow spots
he was a mixed dog just a mutt you know
but he was a great dog and i took him in
he was my first dog
i made a lot of mistakes when i hit him
in the newspaper because they told me to
do you know and i put his nose and piss
because they told me to do but i didn't
enjoy doing it but i was too stupid to
not know you know
you know when my mother died i had to
live with the benders you know i had to
get rid of the dog yeah and i tell you
man until today that [ __ ] heats me
and another story people don't know is
after about two months after my my mom
died
i jumped the fence i got so [ __ ] up
one night and the pain was so
overbearing
not only of my mother but of giving that
[ __ ] dog away that i jumped the fence
where he was living the people would
leave him out at night
and i would jump the fence and and play
with him and one night the lady came out
and
she invited me in and she goes you're
[ __ ] up you know i was really drunk
you know i wreaked of alcohol i probably
had a loot in me and i was
doing a little coke but
that was the last piece of me so when i
looked at those cats yesterday i was
like i hope that doesn't happen to them
you know
because it's tough getting home for all
the cats the girls are too fat you know
nobody's gonna take them
but i know damon will take fidel out of
respect and i know you'll take harry and
demi because you can't take one of them
right you gotta take the brothers
johnson together
and then somebody who has a coke prom or
somebody who needs help should take
super bad because he helped me get off
the coke and let me tell you some soup
bad's a great [ __ ] cat and it's you
know he's he's no [ __ ] cat show with
her you know by no means he's he's got a
little head his body's [ __ ] up really
yeah he lost his fang
you know but super bad has magical
[ __ ] powers
i'm down you man that cat is [ __ ]
magical that cat
listen i saved his life
and he saved my life
and i'm very uh
what's the word i'm looking for
i owe him yeah
but
in his mind he owes me
like we say that cat was dead on my
bathroom floor it was the saddest thing
ever
and me and my wife fed him oatmeal
cookies that's the only thing here we
he didn't have the power to get up so i
give him water and he licked the water
off my finger
and i'd take an oatmeal cookie
and finally he started flipping around
and they would pop his head up
and then one day he fully got up and he
peed himself from the excitement i had
to wash him
and that cat
i tell you uh i had a friend that was
into cam one day he told me those cats
are very appreciative
you don't know that but they're very
repeat they don't forget dick they go
under the bed and they write everything
down and i know super bad like how all
those cats super beds are closest to me
demi loves his mother
last night they were in the shower yeah
i had to do something as i was leaving i
went in there and dimmies in the [ __ ]
you know dimmies with my wife all the
time and that baby he's in the room with
them he's meow meow
the baby chases him now the baby tells
him get the [ __ ] out of here you know
she doesn't say get the [ __ ] out of here
but you know
the language i'm sure she's telling them
to get the [ __ ] out of it but i thought
about those cats
i'm like what would happen to those cats
i gotta tell you something i was [ __ ]
sad for five minutes
because i wouldn't want them to get
abused i wouldn't want them to go to
some home and get killed you know like
some shelter
you know the girls ah the girls are
tough
i can't evie's mean
nobody would take evie evie's mean
that's that mean evie's mean she loves
me and she loves terry and she stays
away from the baby
but she's just a different planet you
know yeah great great you could just if
something happens to me you just get
great put it on the stoop
and at the great takes care of yourself
grey's just in love now gray's my girl
you know grace sleeps at me yeah in the
middle of my just reach my hand on
raising a little bundle she's good man
she comes over and i grab her and i hold
her and i pet her ears and i clean
inside her ears and i clean her eyes for
her and my nose gets wet and then she
sneezes and she sneezes on my face with
a little [ __ ] wet and then i kiss her
and she [ __ ] takes off and i won't
see you for two [ __ ] days
so it's just amazing uh the love that
you get for your animals and how you
gotta worry about them you gotta look at
them and go who's gonna take care of
them like me
after i'm gone you know so we remember
you got harry and yeah oh no [ __ ] yeah
harry and demi move right in with you
right into the bedroom they'll love you
because if you separate those two i
separated one i put one in one car and
one in the other car it was a [ __ ]
nightmare oh no oh it was a nightmare
harry loves demi
harry loves his brother even though he
bites him and they fight and they attack
each other
he loves his [ __ ] brother it's
amazing well i've
i've learned a lot from those goddamn
cats you know so that's funny no but i
don't think uh
i mean no yeah i don't think it's even
not gonna happen hopefully no it's not
gonna happen but you always gotta think
you gotta always think of the dark side
the other side lee if you don't you're
foolish just for two seconds yeah just
to see how it makes you feel you know
and that's it [ __ ] what else
you want you're staring at me going joey
what you just broke my heart with that
no it's the truth you got to think of
the other side or you want to want just
every once in a while think of the other
side for two minutes see how you feel
and move yourself back and what you
could do to take that feeling away yeah
you know what can i do i just asked lee
to take
super bad and [ __ ] demi or something
happened so that's it that's all i got
for you
how about you everything good your
birthday good it's good
i got drunk for the first time like a
year and a half that's funny when you
had sex look at you all depleted
yo it was a happy birthday
you [ __ ] had a good time from vegas
you made good rides i'm proud of you
yeah it was fun it was a blast and this
week you got to go to the gym how many
times
i don't i i took the day off yesterday
so probably hopefully at least five or
six times
and you went saturday
no [ __ ]
i was gonna go remember i brought my bag
to the to the party like
well i'll go to the gym have i have some
lunch i was like oh we get to vegas i
call him up because i'm just getting
dressed to go to the gym i go jim you're
[ __ ] vegas
he shows up at the jambalaya joint with
this bag like he's [ __ ] uh chill son
he's in the gym he's showing up with a
bag like he's got [ __ ] syringes in
there and [ __ ]
scales and whatnot like what's in there
goes i got my my [ __ ] sneakers
whatever the [ __ ]
and uh i said we're gonna go to the gym
you're in vegas go get your dick sucked
do something
go play some [ __ ] games sure enough
we want to play black we both win he's
the kiss of debt yeah i had the [ __ ]
machine by ten dollars and awesome he
sat next well you told me to play he's
like a [ __ ] chinese dude you've been
wanting money and chunk kennedy's uncle
stands behind you you lose a bunch of
[ __ ] money don't let chinese people
stand behind you and don't let jews sit
next to you on the on the what were we
playing
oh you were playing video poker that's
right video poke i don't even know what
the [ __ ] i'm doing you know that no i
have no idea i was watching you i was
like what is
oh i just learned myself anyway i love
you [ __ ] have a great day we'll
be back wednesday
rocking the house nine o'clock at night
maybe i'll let you guys know i love you
guys joeydears.net for all your tour
dates g patches
t-shirts mugs
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you need go
there i love you guys have a great day
and thank you very much for listening
today all right stay safe stay black and
most important stay beautiful
[ __ ] do you have any any dates
i got i got pioneer underground and reno
get your [ __ ] together and next
wednesday a very special live podcast at
the ice house eight o'clock
july the 30th [ __ ] be there or be
[ __ ] square
now the show's over don't forget to sign
up for your free trial of hulu plus
hulu more enthusiastic hulu plus cox
suckers i'm very enthusiastic
they got that they wanna
they let you binge on thousands of shows
anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast and get an extended free trial
of hulu plus when you go to huluplus.com
joey or just go to joeydiaz.net and
click on the hulu plus banner and also
don't forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
razer sent to your door every month for
a fraction of what you pay at retail now
go to dollarshaveclub.com forward slash
church or just go to joeydiaz.net and
click on the dollar shave club banner
also go to audit.com get all of your
optimization uh things like the
supplements and all the everything they
have there imagine church and get 10 off
and go to escape podtank.com for your
sensory deprivation tank needs mention
that you heard about it them on the
church and they'll give you an
additional 250 all